So this is the framework that we're going to be using
through most of the discussions that we'll be having at least
on reinforcement learning. The single
agent reinforcement learning, and it's called
the Markov Decision Process. This should sound familiar to you, Michael.
>> Well, you did say we're going to talk about decisions.
>> That's true, and we need a process for making decisions. And we're going
to introduce something called the Markovian property
as a part of this discussion and
I'll tell you exactly what that means in a moment.
So, I'm just going to write out this frame work and
just, and tell you what it is and what the
problem it produces for us. And then we're going to start
talking about solutions through the rest of the discussion. So
a Markov Decision Process tries to capture worlds like this
one by dividing up in the following way. We say
that there are states. And states are a set of tokens
that somehow represent every state, for lack of a better word, that
one could be in. So, does that make sense to you, Michael?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> So what would the states be in the
world that we've been playing around in so far?
>> So, the only thing that differs from
moment to moment is where, I guess, I am.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Like, which grid, grid position I'm in.
>> Right.
>> So, I feel like each different grid position I could
be in is a state, maybe there's a state for being successfully
done or unsuccessfully done?
>> It's possible. But let's stick with the simple one. I
like that one because that's really, I think, easy to grasp. So,
there are at least, of all the states one could reach,
there's, well let's see there's four times three minus one, since you
can never reach this state. Although we could say it is
a state we just happen to never reach it. So, at most
if we just think of this grid literally as a grid there
are something like twelve different states. And we can represent these states
as their X,Y coordinates, say. We could call
this, the start state as say 1,1, which
is sort of how I described it earlier. We could describe the goal state as 4,4.
And say this is how we describe our
states. Or frankly, it doesn't matter. We could
call these states 1,2,3 up to 12. Or we could name them Fred and Marcus. It
doesn't really matter. The point is
that they're states, they represent something, and
we have some way of knowing which state we happen to be in. Okay?
>> Sure.
>> Okay.